(hip hop music)
- Dad, one thing I talk a lot about
is how much you work, right?
Like my work ethic completely
inspired by you and mom,
the way she worked the
house, but more you.
We really didn't hang out.
Like, you know.
- No you got fired
- [Voiceover] The number you
dialed is not in service.
- We don't need to talk
about when I got fired,
the one time.
- Well why not.
- Fine listen
- Tell them
Build the character
- Go on tell them the story
- Gary asked for
- Two hours off.
Not a day off, left, asked to
leave early for a high school
party, you know when you
graduate high school people
have parties?
I asked on a Saturday to leave
to five instead of seven PM.
And I worked every summer day, these are,
this is real stuff.
- No questions about it
- I asked to leave at five
instead of seven, one day.
And we would leave the house
at seven to open the store.
So seven to five, or nine to five,
I don't care what you think.
You know, two hours early,
hanging up on this one hold on,
I gotta tell this story.
He looked me dead in the
face and said, 'you're not
committed to the business, you're fired'.
- He came home and he was crying.
And of course his mother
had to get involved.
- And then I was, I went
from crying, cuz I cried, to
smiling because I actually
didn't work the next day and
since I'd been working my whole
high school life I was like
wait a minute, this is, I'm
like, this is interesting.
- Give me a lap down
- Little AJ, I didn't.
Not yet, this was before that.
- Right because Joe
- This was 94.
This was playing Nintendo.
- That was the Rangers' year.
- Right so I was like this is amazing.
And then my dad, didn't come
to apologize, he just walked
in my room the next day and
goes 'you're coming to work'
- That's it.
- That's really what happened.
(music)
- You know what's so crazy,
because he was such an
absolute failure with academics,
you can hold that over
anybody who got B's.
You're like, you got B's dude?
You square-ass motherfucker
that got B's and C's.
I'm like Jesus.
- It's so crazy how like
entrepreneurship and like, it's
like on the, like I'm living
in a Bizzaro world I'm like
fuck this, if I was making
$4000 a weekend when I was 12,
in 2017, I'd be like fucking,
genius, the next this.
I was getting shit on by
everybody because I didn't read
Catcher in the Rye.
You know, over the weekend.
(laughter)
- Um, so back to what
we were talking about.
- Did you pause because you
were like fuck I read that in
one hour.
- No, no, no
- Yes, straight up.
Guys, post that in, put
A's all over his face.
- No, no, no,
- Jake I want A's all over his face.
- No!
This is 100% why.
He keeps going, he was like
there are, you guys know this,
there's like 15 videos in the
IG video of him being like
I was a loser, I was a loser,
people called me a loser for
getting D's and F's.
You fucking suck.
(music)
- Here's something that
nobody else will tell you.
If somebody goes to a restaurant
for the first time and has
a flawless experience, the
statistical likelihood of them
doing a second visit is about 40%.
They come back a second time
- Yeah I'd believe that.
- And have a flawless
experience, the statistical
likelihood of a third
visit is still about 42%.
The third time they come,
the statistical likelihood of
a fourth visit is over 70%.
- Whoa.
- So, you gotta market
to three visits, not one.
Visit one, free rib dinner
- Wow that's huge.
- You sit em down, put a red
napkin on the table, not a
white one.
Identify them as a first time
customer, connect with them
and work to get them back a
second time and a third time.
Once they're there a
third time, you own em.
- My man, Chandler,
- The red napkin thing
is genius, holy cuz you know
in a fast, casual environment,
we're not hitting that table a lot but.
- Let me give you
- A napkin that's red.
- Chandler let me give you
- Can I detail that for him?
- Go ahead.
- Okay so you put a red napkin
at the table, Gary sits down,
he's eating his dinner, now he's getting
his free rib dinner, all his
water will cost him nothing.
I know he's a first time
customer because he's got a
red napkin.
When he's leaving the manager
comes to the table writes on
the back of a business card,
five dollars off chicken.
Did you like the ribs?
Loved em.
You gotta try my chicken,
come in for the chicken.
Now I'm prompting a second
visit, not with a printed
coupon, a handwritten card.
- Yeah.
- Now he comes in for the
second visit, drops the business
card on the table, everybody
knows this is the second visit.
Cuz red napkin was the first visit.
Second visit you finish the
meal you go up you say so
how was the chicken?
It was fricken great.
Are you full, totally stuffed.
Man, next time you
gotta try my cheesecake.
Free piece of cheescake.
Now, three visits.
- Wait a pizza?
- A piece of cheesecake.
- Oh I thought a pizza
flavored cheesecake I was like
that's fuckin brilliant.
- Okay so the rib dinner cost
me five dollars, the chicken
was a washout because it was
a discount, the cheesecake
is a dollar 35.
For about six dollars you got
three visits out of him with
a 70% likelihood of a fourth.
That's the way you market your
restaurant within the four
walls of it.
(music)
- Jewel for the four people
who may not know who you are,
why don't you give a little
context of, a little bit about
your career and who you are.
- Okay my name is Jewel, it's
my real name, these are my
real teeth, nobody asks me
that but I just thought I'd
throw it out there.
I'm from Alaska my family were pioneers.
I grew up on a homestead, which
means I grew up eating only
what I could kill or can.
So my fang came in really handy.
It didn't actually.
It taught me resilience, it
taught me grit, it taught me
how to grind.
It taught me self esteem from
the inside out which is being
able to understand that you're
capable because you've been
given the opportunity to struggle
which is a real blessing.
And I ended up moving out at
15, I ended up homeless at 18,
was shoplifting.
- Why'd you originally move out at 15.
- My dad was abusive and so I
decided I would just live in
a cabin by myself.
We'd been pretty transient,
moved around a lot.
And I'd taken care of myself
quite a long time so I wanted
to do it on my own, without
somebody in the cabin
besides myself.
So too young to drive, I was
hitchhiking into work, at a
pretty young age, working multiple jobs.
- Where?
- In Homer, Alaska.
And then I got a scholarship
to an amazing art school in
a roundabout way in Michigan.
Was able to graduate high school, yay me.
And most importantly, if I
look back on my life, I knew
that at 15 I should've been a statistic.
When I was homeless, I ended
up homeless when I was about
18, I turned down the
advances of my boss and when I
wouldn't have sex with him, he
wouldn't give me my paycheck.
And so I thought no big deal,
I'll live in my car for a
couple of months and
I'll get back on my feet.
But then the car I was living
in got stolen and so that's
how I ended up homeless and I
started having panic attacks
I began shoplifting a lot.
So I found a coffee shop, it
was going out of business.
And I said hey before you
close your doors, give me two
weeks and give me all the door
money and you can have all
the coffee and the sales and food.
And so we struck a deal and
I suddenly had to go out and
get a following, and I had
to write a bunch of songs.
Cuz I grew up singing
cover songs with my dad.
So I wrote and wrote and
wrote, I handed out flyers, I
hustled, I had two people
in my coffee shop the first
night, and I sang a five hour set.
And I sang my heart out.
And what I learned is
that I was very lonely.
And a lot of people are lonely,
and I deserved to be lonely
because I only told truth
in one place and it was in a
notebook that nobody read.
And I decided to take a risk
and be vulnerable and talk
about what was real and
not hide from the truth.
And so I poured all of my
feelings out in front of these
two surfers, bless their hearts.
- By the way if you're watching,
either one of the surfers,
please leave a comment.
(laughter)
They're like holy shit I was that dude.
- Yeah and then the next week
four people, the next week
seven, I played there every
week to try and have a very
regular time.
And after about a year, it
was sold out and people were
standing outside the windows,
standing in pouring rain for
five hours listening
to me through a window.
And a radio put a bootleg
of mine on the air, it ended
up requested and I got
into the top ten countdown.
Top ten countdown on 91X in
San Diego, it's one of the
biggest stations in the country.
Labels were like who the
heck is this girl on acoustic
guitar playing between
Nirvana and Soundgarden?
They all started showing up so
it was like being Cinderella.
You know limousines were showing up.
- Really?
- Yeah.
So you'd think I would jump
at the opportunity to have a
record label, or a record
deal, except that I had just
found happiness and I was
not going to give it up.
And fame is a path so many
people lose their footing on.
- It's happening to D-Rock,
he's changing so much.
- He is, I just watched
it right here, he's very
condescending, the way he stares at me.
(laughter)
- So you were really trying to be careful.
- Yeah and so I had to ask
myself some very serious
questions.
Why am I doing this?
It's very important to
know if you want to end up
somewhere, you have to know
where you want to end up.
Then you have to have a compass
of knowing how to navigate.
So for me I was at an artist, or famous.
I knew I wanted to be an
artist, nothing against fame, by
the way, it's just which one
do you want as an experience
for your life.
I wanted to be an artist,
so everyday I made decisions
based on being an artist,
not being famous or rich.
- And that's that.
- And the other kind of
interesting caveat is that I was
offered a million dollar
signing bonus and I turned it
down.
I read a book called everything
you need to know about
the music business, and I
learned that it was an advance,
and that you owed the advance back.
I knew I was gonna make a
folk record, at the height of
grunge, and I knew that the
odds of that working were
incredibly slim.
And so I basically bought
my own right to make my own
music and I negotiated the
biggest backend anybody had
ever been given in
royalties and mechanicals.
- Same thing I did with Crush It.
- Nice I love it.
- I didn't want, that's so funny.
- Yeah bet on yourself
- 100% if you're good enough
bet on yourself.
- Yeah.
And I turned down reality tv
shows and a lot of shortcut
things, but there's no
shortcut to being great.
So I did 600, 700 shows a year
and I did it for years and
I grinded it out and
ended up breaking through.
But yes, I've always looked
at myself entrepreneurially.
To answer your question in
a really round about way.
- It's true, it's great,
it's really great.
(music)
- Tim you said something
earlier about, you know, you've
gotta be right to be able to
do the right thing by others.
- Yeah.
- I, you know, it was interesting,
and you know this, this
is, we have an interesting,
great, long relationship, but
I really want to use this medium to
publicly apologize to you.
This is something I've done to you
personally a lot of times.
I am so thankful for the life that I live.
I am such a happy man because
I like really have like
crazy good intent, and have
been able to execute it a bunch.
This is something nobody knows here,
I'm excited for everybody,
Tyler, and people that know who
I am, and I know that you know who I am.
But I wanted to do it because
I thought it was important
for me because I want you to
know how much it means to me.
Because I've done it a
bunch of times personally.
Early in my career, I
was giving a speech at
Blogs with Balls, just funny, so.
I think I got overzealous,
I did get overzealous and I
was talking about hard work and hustle.
And in it, I said, fuck four
hour work weeks, you gotta
work your ass off.
And the level of intent was
extremely low, but in reality
it was just not the right
thing to do, especially because
out of all the people I know on Earth.
The thought that I haven't
offended or hurt or even did
anything slightly wrong to
millions of people that I have
no respect for or compassion
for or desire for friendship
or how I feel about them.
The thought that that happened,
and I just want you to know
and I know I've said it a bunch
of times privately, but in
my everlasting quest for you
to know how deeply I'm hurt
that I could've done anything
that hurt you or miffed you in
any certain way, I wanted to
put it super out there into the
universe and never let
there be any confusion.
I admire you tremendously.
I've really enjoyed our
friendship through the years and
that is, when I do die, that
is something that will still
run through my mind.
I've lived it pretty good, and
have all the right intents.
I hated that that happened.
I hate that that happened.
And I want you to know on this
big of a stage or at least
on my micro big stage that I mean it
with every ounce of my soul.
- Thank you, Gary.
Accepted.
I know you do, we've talked
about it personally so.
- But you mean a lot to me.
- That means a lot so thank you
- I mean honestly like now
as I get older, there's not
that many people doing it.
You know.
The level of, I get put into
a lot of, a lot of people use
my name and associate it with other names,
and I have no interest.
But every time people are like
oh, on Twitter, or in real
life when people are like I
like Tim and Gary, and every
time I'm associated with your
name, it means a lot to me.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome, brother.
I love you.
Good luck
- Many adventures ahead.
- 100% much appreciated.
(music)
- Talk to me about The Hawk, Aaron Pryor.
- The Hawk was one of the
baddest dudes ever dude.
- Baddest dude ever
- I'm a big big Aaron
and they don't know who he is.
- The Hawk was one of
the baddest dudes ever.
- You're made you missed social
media, The Hawk missed it,
you know he just missed it.
- I know that's what I'm
saying, but God knows best, God
knows what he's doing, he
did it for his reasons, and
that's what we have to live with.
- I'm being selfish a couple more.
- But Hawk was a made boy.
- John 'The Beast' Mugabe.
- John 'The Beast'
Mugabe was a killer too.
And Hacklett destroyed him
but he was a killer before
Hacklett destroyed him.
Yes.
- What about Terry Norris?
- Terry Norris was a very
good fighter, a very technical
fighter, I think he probably
did a little too much sparring
in his days because it
kinda got to him at the end.
But before that Terry was a bad boy.
Terry could've played any
sport, boxing, basketball,
football, anything.
- Have you seen Nigel Benz' kid?
- Yes he's pretty good he's strong.
- He looks strong.
- He's strong, he don't have
the technique his dad had
yet, but he's very strong
so they keep working on him
technically, he could be a good fighter.
Eubanks' kid is even better.
- Yeah Eubanks' kid is
- Eubanks' kid is awesome.
- Eubanks was some puncher, huh?
- His son is awesome, yes.
- Interesting.
- They both throw punches, and
both their kids are punchers.
- I know it's interesting like that.
Julian Jackson.
- The Hawk.
His kid isn't trying to be what
he was, but he was a beast.
A menace.
- You guys want to see real knockouts.
- Real knockouts.
- That knockout on Terry
Norris is so vicious.
- [Commentator] The incredible
knockout ratio of Jackson.
And that's right there
Terry Norris is gone.
- That dude there.
- Julian Jackson, and he had
a flat top like Patrick Ewing.
(music)
Real quick, what's the
best flip you've ever had.
- The best one?
- Like the biggest ROI,
like I bought this bike at a
garage sale for $40 and
I sold it for 6,900.
- Nah I didn't have one like that.
- I get it I mean I made that
up, but like give me a real
fucking good one.
- I found a Ferrari 348 Spider
in a guy's garage and was
able to flip that.
I bought it for 20,000 bucks
cuz it didn't run and was able
to flip it for 113,000.
- That was better than the example I gave.
(laughter)
He's like no, no, like I was like.
And how much work and things
did you have to put into it?
- I put fresh gas in it and started it up.
- It started right up.
- Yeah with fresh gas and a
battery, we were good to go.
- By the way I could so get
caught on that cuz I don't
understand cars like.
By the way, that's really interesting.
I don't know if you know this
but all these chotchkas, like
so many people that watch me I
pushed them to this 2017 flip
challenge.
And it's interesting, I know
pop culture so I'm good at like
buying advertising or TV
stuff, buying it, knowing it's
undervalued.
But so many of the people that
watch me have a little bit
more handy skills like you
did, maybe not for bikes and
cars, but whether it's electronics
or things of that nature,
and hearing people on Twitter
and email and DMing me on
Instagram like I bought this
I-this, it didn't work, it
took me one minute it was
the battery then I flipped it
for that, it's amazing.
It's amazing when you have
a skill set to use that as
an arbitrage.
- No it's really cool.
(music)
- Every single day, I make
pretend that my mother, dad,
sister, brother, wife
or children are killed.
Now I know this is a very
different version of it.
(laughter)
I know you didn't expect that one.
- You crazy son of a bitch.
- I know it's a little different.
- Yes they get stabbed in the
eye, and then they take out
the groin.
- Yes it's sometimes even in
detail, but I will tell you,
it's very fleeting, it
usually happens within 20.
- Great that they're still being here.
- But I promise you, I know
it's a little left field, it's
insane what that perspective
does for me, and I feel it.
- Well it's contrast.
- And I feel it, and I feel it in my soul.
- Contrast works.
- And it just makes every bad thing.
And by the way, I'm sure for
your business, when you're the
last line of defense.
You know how they say
occupation on the doctor form?
The last time I filled it
out I said firefighter.
Because that's what I
think I do for a living.
Like it's just problems.
Like when I get done with this
interview and I look at my
phone, seven problems.
Seven fires to put out,
like that's what I do.
For me it's perspective.
Like I don't understand how
people don't get that there's
seven plus billion people, that
there's so many people that
have it worse than you.
- Look if you live in this
country, I feed a hundred million
people a year, I care.
But if you live in poverty in
this country, you're the one
percent, you're not the 99 percent.
- I know.
- Two thirds of the planet lives
on two dollars and 50 cents
a day, 900 dollars a year.
If you're making 18,000 a
year, I don't want you to make
18,000, but you gotta start
with gratitude that you're one
of the richest humans on Earth.
It doesn't feel like it but you are.
(music)
- Happiness, man, it's
just about happiness, bro.
That's all that matters,
is your happiness.
Other people are gonna tell
you what they think you should
do, or what they would do if
they were you, but they're not
you, bro, they're not you.
So just be happy, do what you
love, stay passionate, you
know, be smart and have
fun, and take risk.
- And be a Wuzzle.
Wuzzle was a 1984 cartoon
where two animals were in one
animal.
Be a professional lacrosse
player and a fucking doctor.
And grandma fucking Victor is thrilled.
- Swag, I love how we're talking
to 14 year old kids today
it's awesome.
- [Phone] Yeah I mean I like,
if you look at lacrosse,
lacrosse is growing like
disgustingly fast and that's
- Dude I'm 41 and lacrosse
has been growing disgustingly
fast since I was 14 so be
careful, but it doesn't matter
be happy and execute on your thing.
Don't justify your
dreams, execute on them.
Ooh.
- Yo put that shit on a shirt, bro.
- That's actually what 'ooh' was.
Alright Victor, we gotta go
my man, we wish you well.
- [Phone] Alright, see ya, thanks logic.
- Peace
- Alright one more.
- Damn that was crucial.
- Yeah don't just like
- Damn
this is tight.
- This is fun right?
- This is cool as shit.
- I'm gonna see like 'Ask
Logic' in a couple weeks on
YouTube, you should do this man.
- Yeah it's fun
- It's fun right?
- Yeah this dope, thank you.
This is a really good experience.
- And so a good way to
scale interaction with fans.
- I like this energy.
- Do you think we should
start a morning show?
Like me and you versus
like Kelly and Michael.
I guess they like
- That'd be great.
- You said you wanted to do TV.
- I'll wear the dress.
- I'll wear it too, we'll both wear it.
- Alright.
- Here we go.
- You know the person's
name, or you didn't catch it.
- Lafonda.
- Lafonda you're on the Ask Gary Vee show.
- What is it?
- Alright we'll get it.
Alright relax over there guys.
Sticking phones in each other's pockets.
- [Phone] Hello?
- Yo this is Gary Vee you're
on the Ask Gary Vee show.
With Logic.
(call dropped noise)
(laughter)
- They got scared, they were
like you could hear us in
the background they got excited.
(music)
- T-Pain, you get to ask
the question of the day.
Everyone who comes on as a
guest gets to ask the Veener
nation the question of the day.
This is an opportunity for
you to get market research or
curiosity of something answered.
Thousands of comments and
answers will show up on YouTube.
And Facebook.
- I got a question that's
got nothing to do with
what's going on.
- That's exactly what
I thought would happen.
(laughter)
- Fire it away, T-Pain.
- Okay.
I've been asking this question
all around the world and I
will keep asking this question
until Neil DeGrasse Tyson
answers this goddamn question.
If we go back in time, follow me on this.
(laughter)
- Let me get settled in.
- Right.
If we go back in time, we know
the Earth moves through the
universe right, so the Earth
is moving, continuously.
If we go back in time.
- I failed science
- Do we go back to where the
Earth was at that time, and
we just, that's why, I
think this is why we don't
- Okay when did this
question come to your head.
- So, so long ago.
- I can feel that.
(laughter)
- When, no
- Because the Earth
- T-Pain! No, no when
- Moves through the Universe
- When and why.
- Time travel.
Have you guys not been
thinking about time travel?
- Jake?
(laughs)
- So if we're moving,
- I have never
- If we're always moving through time.
- Thought about time
travel until this moment.
- If we're always moving
through time and space, and we
go back in time, do we go
back to where the Earth was?
That's why you don't see
time travelers, because they
just end up in a fucking void, somewhere.
- Oh wait a minute that was
actually interesting are you
telling me that I could go
back in time and stay alive
longer, I'm just living in 1437.
- No.
- Okay what are you saying.
- I'm saying that if the
Earth is moving through the
Universe, when you go back in time.
- Wait can we establish the
when you go back in time.
Who's gone back in time, how
have they gone back in time.
- There are time machines.
- Where.
- They're in the fucking void
where the Earth used to be.
They went back in time and
obviously died like in the void
of space it's like fucking
Arnold Schwarzenegger on total recall.
Head blew up, it's crazy,
there's a lot going on.
I got footage, I don't have footage.
(laughter)
So if the Earth is moving
through the Universe, when you
go back in time do you go
back to where the Earth was or
does the Earth go back with you.
- I don't know if I've ever
been more curious to see the
answers on YouTube and Facebook for this .
T-Pain
- I'm ready I'm so ready.
- I appreciate this
- Absolutely.
- Album dropping November 17th
- That's some quantum shit I just dropped.
- You did.
You're the science
professor up in this bitch.
(music)